Serhat 570s down no movement. We're gonna need additional units
They didn't have to kill him like that they didn't have to shoot him that many times
Detectives they came in and kept telling me don't go outside or go in and back
I said,  "What happened? I hope y'all didn't kill one of my grandkids because they come through the back door
My grandson was 23 years old
And now my great grandbabies don't have their daddy
Because they didn't even... why didn't you just shoot him in the arm. Shoot him in the leg, send the dogs, send a Taser, why, why
Y'all didn't have to do that
Y'all didn't have to over a cell phone
I just want justice for my grandson. My daughter my baby is in so much pain.
Justice I want justice for my baby. I want justice for Stephon Clark. Please give us justice
One be careful sir be careful I
Never hate that moves. Oh, what if you have one of these? This is dark, and that's my good weapon it does in your hand
What does that look like
Hey there wait wait wait wait watch this watch this
What does it look like in my hand?
Cellphone this is a magic trick now watch this again watch this cellphone. I watched this
Was my brother
25 split ties